e
e e
013 8 h 8 H 1 3
8h
okay okay uh so U for the T for this sub
committee uh we we actually have uh well
we
have we we have six six of us who are on
the committee are here so and that's uh
myself pusc Ammon Herbert melier
spear okay so represent Ammon second by
representative Spears moved ought to
pass as amended on the amendment 0138 is
there any discussion on the motion see
none all those in favor please raise
your
hand question we do have a discussion
yes in terms of gold I know gold ised to
be
right you have to use the microphone
sorry not paying attent you you got to
pull it closer I understand the uh the
gold
is traded traded quite you know a lot of
it but uh I I came across that or
somebody told me that the our gold
standard the gold that we already
have and and it's in the treasury I
guess uh the unit St treasury Fort Knox
it's fort fort well Fort New York I
think uh but the uh but the but it had a
stated
value in other words it's not traded and
so I was wondering I think Trump
actually U I think that's what got me
interested Trump said he wanted to raise
uh put put that gold into the market and
because it's three four five six seven
times
uh above the U uh the
bookkeeping uh on on the government it
that our gold is it it's exactly what
happened with FDR I mean FDR had the the
gold was like 32 bucks an ounce
something like that and and then they uh
then they uh he lifted it no there and
that's how he raised Cas not that I'm
any expert on this issue so Keith you'll
help me out but my memory was that yes
we used to be on the gold standard okay
and we he took us off the gold standard
but yet the gold is still on our balance
sheet so that it rep it represents uh to
anyone who is concerned about in
investing in the dollar or exchanging
the dollar that yes we do have uh a hard
asset behind it but it's obviously not
transferred it's not you know it's it's
just uh nothing else is security it's
collateral I I just uh thought that
Trump said that on the bookkeeping I I
really pay little little attention to
what he says I'm sorry I just don't pay
any attention it's got nothing to do
with this bill right he we have learned
already that he says things and hasn't
really F thought it through but yes
represent Ammon yes so uh just to
clarify the gold that we have for the
government it's stat
statutorily def fined as
$422 an ounce and the market value is
2900 so the the the treasury is treating
the gold as much lower value because a
statute was put in in
1973 and that the actual market value
was way over multiple multiple times
that $2,000 so I was just wondering
what's what's the impact if any on on
this particular piece of
legislation uh the the impact is is that
the state treasurer has to rationalize
investing in gold well the treasur she
has to explain she has some explaining
to do and but that the fact that the
federal government has a lower list
price but it's actually exchanging on
the Open Market at a much higher price
it that just has nothing to do with it
it just it just shows you that we're
under the federal government is
undervaluing that collateral so we're
we're obviously going to be trading at
the US market there's something that
needs to be said when we were when we
were in with the treasurer talking about
this she said you can write what you
want in here and that gives her tools to
work with but she's got a board of
directors and she's got uh evaluation
services like uh standard and Po's Moody
yeah that she's not going to move on any
of this this is not telling her to
actually invest in gold this is saying
sometime in the future if it looks like
a good investment go ahead and and if
Moody's changed his attitude towards it
that's my question I just uh I I knew
there was a discrep I I'm glad you
brought it up and we would have to buy
and I've learned something new today
we'd have to buy that market value so
the statutory price we would not be able
to I'm pretty sure the federal
government is not going to sell it to
us2 they're not selling there's no for
sale sign on Fort Knox okay no special
this week okay okay uh is the question
are we ready to vote now yes sir okay
all those in favor about to pass on the
amendment please raise your hand 1 2 3 4
five six beautiful okay representative
Ammon representa
spear seconds ought to pass on the
amendment as amended all those in favor
raise your hand one two three four five
six okay and Keith this means you're
going to write the blur and please have
it ready before we do it next you know
two week
weeks we uh the
fifth
okay
okay okay who's one second next up
639 can I get my sheet just for a minute
you can have your it back to you
I don't need
it okay 639 there we
go okay all right 639 so uh
representative Ammon has passed out an
amendment uh he just passed it out so
hopefully you have one nearby you
0445 uh
0445 okay so what's in here what are we
left
with
yeah right so um
why don't you give us the global what
globally did you remove from this
bill
Mike in talking to folks about the
private key aspect we decided that it
was best to just remove that from the
bill instead of bicker over it um so
that's been deleted the whole private
key
thing um I took out two definitions so
one is home digital asset mining I took
that
out and and private key that those two
definitions were no longer
used uh let's
see 39
V2 is that
page holding in use of private digital
currency page three is that on the
new page
three right so this is what uh
holding that curs
uh okay so right now um we were just
mentioning on page three we have on line
six is the holding and use of private
digital currencies do we change anything
in that
paragraph no that's the same okay so the
paragraph We did change is start on
14 that's right it's line 21 on page
three on the amendment right
line 22 so that's the new language that
we discussed
in no state or local government agency
or subdivision thereof shall set a
specific limit on sound decimals
generated from noise including digital
asset lining other than the limit set by
the political subdivision and any local
noise
ordinances and then we Str so this is
based on feedback this is based on
feedback from the municipal Association
John you'd asked me to reach out to them
they took a look at it um even though
the fiscal note said they looked at it
uh they said they didn't see it so so
now they have and they uh suggested
striking some things which I took out
there was a there was an old number
B that had to do with specific limits of
decb they said that that wasn't
needed
and the the SEC the
uh the line that says it's line
24 that used to be much longer so now it
just says impose any requirement on
digital asset mining business that does
not equally apply to all industrial
zones there was something about a
positive incentive for encouraging
staking and they said they
don't they said municipalities don't
have a way to incentivize things so that
was Su
Superfluous and then I took out U making
a Zone a zoning change to an area with
the digital asset mining Business
Without conducting all required notice
and hearing procedures they said that
has to be done anyway we don't need to
State
it and then there was another thing
notwithstanding RSA 677 or any related
provision of law talked about a
court court shall prohibit any zoning
change if the change was made to
determine against the digital asset
mining business they said that that
that's not needed either
so so those were that section's probably
half the size that it was y uh question
Keith what what about the use of
electricity uh that's later on in the
bill that's discriminatory
rate
see so discriminatory rates is defined
in the
definitions okay there's the definition
so where's the reference to it in the
Statue uh it is a new number four
just have a lot of red lining I'm going
through here right it's in that same
section we were just reviewing I assume
should be the
next it's line 26 on page
three a rate schedule for digital asset
mining creates a discriminatory rate for
digital asset mining businesses it just
clearly says that the rates have to be
the same you know
you can't just pick that business and
say you're going have a higher
R then the right to private Keys section
was
removed and right I told you we we was
easier to just get rid of the whole
paragraph and give that charge to the
oversight commission to re rethink that
piece changes um
[Music]
um I probably missed this but uh are we
going to have a regulatory uh um
division that is
specifically um I mean is Commerce going
to be the regulator here this committee
or is it going to be the treasurer uh
well in terms of which paragraph of the
bill you're talking about well we're we
this is a whole currency thing and and
I'm where where do you Curren
be well the holding in use of private
digital currency is just simply that no
no state or government agency would
restrict it so who's the enforcer of
that well who's who's yeah if some some
local government does it someone can
take them to court and say they
violated well is that the someone
division of the the government I mean uh
well Attorney General Attorney General's
office yeah that would either attorney
or or banking counts on how and what was
the it what was the nature of the
situation that that Government tried to
pass that resol come in under Commerce
under this
committee true there's no but and also
the attorney general and consumer
protection comes under this committee so
yes we are the we are the regulator of
the
statute
okay which really frightens me but uh
that you're on
but I was just trying to figure out if
they were going to have a a a group of U
experts in treasury or or in in the
government full-time who are
monitoring and uh you would you would if
you had a problem that's who you would
go
to well I I guess which SE the bill
you're talking about but the section
we've been talking about right now yeah
where it says no state or local
government agency no state or local
government agency that's written three
times that no regulator in that
case that if some state or Local
Government tried to do what this says
you can't do you would sue them they
would be sued were well actually their
legal beagles would tell them don't do
it because it's illegal so it wouldn't
happen
all right I'm to me that sounds like
you're not you're not being
regulated uh we are what we are saying
in these particular pie you have to
remember what the purpose of this bill
is and and I would say on the on the
face of it I generally am not for
prophylactic legislation I use that word
because that's what Neil Kirk taught me
to use okay some some people call it
proactive Jesus
some people call Proactive at any rate
normally I don't do that I usually wait
till the plane crashes and then figure
out you know how to solve it why are you
doing it now because after this whole
debate around zoning right now and how
the state is now stepping in and trying
to tell cities and towns what to do okay
and I don't agree with that okay because
they delegated that Authority that
really if the state didn't want to do
that or they didn't that should have
done it upfront and that's what this
this bill means to me is that we're
saying right now ahead of
time that do not
treat digital currency don't treat
blockchain
mining uh as as as different than any
other zoning regulation if when it comes
to utility
and it comes to noise that whatever new
noise ordinance you want to pass in your
town it's got to be fair and proportion
and not t
targeting digital
currency and that's and that's the
reason why I'm in support of this
bill okay represent Bros yeah I have a
question um I don't think we went over
it but so you know when you have too
many air conditioners on the system can
crash so
what's to protect you know a
neighborhood or an area for their you
know too much utilization of electric
power yeah that's a good question I mean
just like any other large load would
have to you know likely get uh approval
through the Pu process you know if they
need if they need large uh interconnects
for large amount of electricity but also
like the rates themselves right
so you kind of have to break out of like
the scarcity mentality that using
electri electricity is is a bad thing it
using electricity incentivizes the
creation of more distribution more
generation right and so over time the
the uh the system corrects itself right
follow up though okay but you know I
live with you know I live in uh a big
apartment complex and you know it's a
really hot day everybody's got their air
conditioner on and it goes kaput so I'm
going to be concerned about the same
thing um with this and you know is it
going to impact my ability to run my air
conditioner to run my computer and all
that kind of stuff I think I I want to
weigh in on this okay okay and that is
uh what I know about utilities okay and
that is um you hear all the time about
rolling blackouts okay you hear about
how they're actually telling people to
turn off devices okay now that clearly
that's voluntary they're they're telling
you ahead of time to do that but it's
really voluntary what I would say is is
in terms of um how a utility monitors
and making sure that there's plenty of
power okay um we have we have there is
the base rate know the rate for the
consumer rate okay and then you have the
corporate business rates okay and but
then you're right now that buying that
wholesale power is different each each
one of our bills can be different okay
you could signed up for a different
power producer than I'm signed up for
but in any case the utility has um is is
uniquely to you know paying attention to
temperature rises to variations to
making that prediction and ensuring that
there's enough power you know going to
be enough power so that they don't have
to it's not a power breakout problem it
really is not a power breakout and and I
have to say but I I just got to throw
this humorous aspect in that is that um
even though we had my wife says I snore
too much and we do have a noise maker
you know I have a noise maker right now
her noise maker of choice is the air
conditioner and we run it in the
wintertime at
night I'm telling you we have the noise
maker but she wants that AC and she cuz
it also drops the temperature in the
room she just loves that thing so the
irony is that AC's really are a
good so there there's a seat up here for
you so and
so may I say one thing just in response
um what's interesting about digital
asset mining is it can be a very large
load and then in a few minutes it can
turn down to almost nothing right so
it's a variable load and what that what
that does through the price signals in
the electric grid it it uses extra
electricity so when electricity is cheap
they're running when the price goes up
because there's too much demand they
shut off and they sort of absorb the
extra capacity on the grid so that's
something that people don't quite
understand I think that one of the
things that this bill does is it
tells
okay we're still here right just that's
why I'm see I'm seeing all these people
enter in the room okay okay no problem
no problem you are on this the
subcommittee okay and I'm I'm just
missing a couple Republicans so you're
you're on
now just trying to keep it fair and
balanced okay so we have hunt pusk Ammon
Walsh Herbert melier Spear and
salvi all right so um any other
questions about this amendment I would
like to make one of the things that I
see that's that's kind of good about
having something like this is it gives
local communities what they need to aim
at right exactly and they can say well
all right from now on our noise level in
this town is going to be whatever it
actually gives them the tools they need
to say I better start aiming at some of
this stuff not that I would ever do
anything like that of course but some
people might no I think it's good giving
them guidance it's a good thing okay
representative Herbert um it's
be very obvious but uh
um crypto Bitcoin is quite volatile in
terms of its pricing in the market and
uh so I'm I'm
questioning um what might be the impact
of paying the electric bill for the
who's saying for the minor no no that no
they still got to pay pay in dollars
this is not this is not giving them an
opportunity to pay their electric bill
in Bitcoin okay they it's totally
distinct it's going to be a dollar it's
going to be dollar okay their electric
bills cannot change that's the whole
point it can't be discriminatory it
can't be different yes I left one thing
out of the things that we removed from
the bill and it's just coming to me the
blockchainbased trusts section is
removed and I think we'll put it in 310
to study it I think it's a great idea
but it just needs a little more uh
flushing out you know we get some
experts talking about it
so okay good okay representative
Ammon second by representative
spear moves a to pass on the
amendment number
04 four five
H any discussion on the motion of a to
pass on the amendment seeing none all
those who agree please raise your hand
one two three three four five six seven
those
oppos
okay number
H and put your put your computer on
silent you don't have it on your
keyboard speak over there okay the
motion now is represent M and second by
representative Spears move ought to pass
as
amended any discussion on the
motion see none the clerk the all those
in favor please raise your hand all
those opposed seven to
one one com I would make about this
one right to hear oh one comment I would
make about this one it really doesn't
have anything to do specifically with
Bitcoin or anything like that it has to
do with the
technology of blockchain which can be
used for almost a lot of stuff I've seen
it used for a lot of different things so
I I think we have to you have to open
your mind a little bit about the fact
that it's really not aimed specifically
at Bitcoin in any way
well that's
true okay right 41 we need an amendment
okay paint program all right um so uh I
do have an
amendment but it's all it's in draft
form at this point because this uh this
was a last minute
production two
three
four one
two
three yeah yeah
four
five okay one for me all right all right
so uh this being passed around as you
remember in the public hearing the
discussion was around uh the fee the fee
that fee the infamous fee and um and and
I take full responsibility that what I
was offended by was that this fee
assessment uh would be um I guess some
states thought it was important that
it'd be on the invoice other states
didn't you know but at the end of the
day the whole idea of the fee being
involved and what the fee is and and and
we were putting in Statue what the fee
was going to be that is just that was an
anatema for me um and
what what really you know would I guess
what goed me more than anything else is
is the fee uh which is you initially the
paint manufacturers were supposed to
project what the fee will be that what
their fee would be based upon what they
think they're going to sell and they
give this money over and where does this
money go well it goes to their
subcontractor who is going to organize
who's going to come and pick up the
paints and who's going to do the
displays and everything like that so to
me this seems like you know this is um
I'll choose the bankers they just left
so this is like the bankers are having a
fee and and they're hiring the banker
lobbyist to manage the Fe manage the
program and and I'm just that
just I I just couldn't get behind that
so what this bill does right now is uh
it takes out all statements about the
fee it just simply says there's a plan
will be involved yes they whatever their
plan is they do need to bring it to Dees
to look it over uh and make sure that
that uh they're not doing anything that
that violates our state statutes in
terms of the moving this paint you know
moving the product um represented Cole
at the end mentioned that about the uh
back part of the of the statute which
was the
um
uh uh a liability
section yeah so it's on page 3 149 M7
liability and
disclosure and he he he was interpreting
that that that means um that they would
not be held responsible if they screwed
up with the paint and no that's not what
that's about what this is about is
because this is assessment them on to
themselves all the all the units are
been that in other states who have
implemented this had a problem of a um
CL a uh a uh they
were uh I'm losing sping my mind it was
um that they they were working in
cahoots with each other and it was an
Anti-Trust statute and so that this
paragraph is simply saying is that that
no there's no intent any trust intent
with enabling this
legislation and that's really probably
why we need to pass it in the first
place
so we can let them do that without
having to have that lawsuit but at the
same time it does not change any
enforcement of in terms of the misuse of
the paint in terms that they make a mess
they're still respons get sued about
they can be sued if they you know drop a
you know paint truck on in the middle of
the road or they had some kind of no you
you were mentioning where I I can't
follow where it's said that they
that
gives the liability of where is that
okay so I'm looking right now on on page
three yeah where down at the bottom of
the page
three M having liability and
disclosure okay that's the one I was
about which is really all I wanted right
well and
really it it itan it's much
representative Cole was con concerned
about what the intent of that was um you
know once that was clarified that no
this is only about the antitrust because
they're in cahoots with um hitting
themselves up for this fee but that but
that um so that exempts them from
that take the Mone did you review this
with any of the folks on the on who were
putting this bill forward so Dees has
looked looked it over they're happy okay
and and uh and I guess we got got
members of the paint sitting right who
are I guess are happy right we're all
[Laughter]
happy
this they're they're not they're not
finding anything offensive at this point
about it right as much as you don't like
the fact that you know we we've done it
this way um uh but that the
this is what we do here in New
Hampshire oh okay that's right right
okay yes so this is basically a silent
fee um oh don't bring that I I so in
terms of in terms of what I would I'll
just I'll just kind of put okay I I
don't see way I look at it differently I
look at it this is um a business expense
related to being in the paint
manufacturing business that you have
some
responsibility to what happens to the
unused paint and so therefore really
it's their cost of good sold and and so
if if the IRS asks me I would say that
that that cost is not a revenue to them
or Revenue to The Entity that they you
know they which I assume it's a
nonprofit anyways but that that their
lobbyist group who's running this thing
but that this is a cost to them it
should be on their
books thank
you I have I want to make sure I
understand this uh RSA
356 is uh an
antitrust correct law yes and
um if I read my English
correctly a manufacturer or
representative organization implementing
or participating in a program shall be
exempt from RSA
356 right and that is an trust can do
all these bad things no no
it's are participating in the program
but it's not that it goes on to say that
they still are responsible for any
messes or any cleanups and that they're
accountable for any of those
problems yes yeah yeah I
would identify yourself uh for the
record Jonathan malanson with Demmer
prol and Thomas uh representing the
American codings Association I think to
representative Cole's Point um that that
he brought up last work session um and
to just clarify under the definition
section on page one um we Define
environmentally sound management
practices and I think that's where you
know this spells out any anybody
operating under for this program you
know needs to do so responsibly make
sure that there's not any messes being
made and and so forth so I just wanted
to highlight that for right and you can
see and the appropriate environmental
liability
coverage on page one on page one in red
the only red thing you see there has
been
deleted okay so if for whatever reason
somebody makes a mistake and pollutes
or something
nefarious uh there is going to be a
penalty uh associated with this Behavior
yeah I mean as long as they haven't you
know follow followed the practice and
and that's another reason why you know
you have the plan that would be
submitted to the Department of
Environmental Services so that they have
that oversight as well to make sure that
it's all all being done Dees will get a
crack at exactly what's going
on you've seen this
yeah
right is this the one I assume I assume
they mailed it to
you but we have we haven't had the
amendment drawn up yet because obviously
this happened on Friday
okay okay so the sponsors okay with
this okay we have nobody opposed to it
and we do have someone from the
Department
though and you want to make a comment
just any you're you're
fine you're all good you're all good
okay okay
wonderful uh who would like to make the
motion on this bill
okay represent
spear
melier we don't have an amendment number
yet on on proposed
amendment
okay um so this is a straw
vote because we don't actually have the
amendment in
hand it's a
stra so um no I mean theoretically you
know as a chair I can just take up the
amendment in in our exact session and
say that the uh this this committee and
that but we would make sure that the
language is exactly what we think it is
so okay so this is a straw vote um all
those in favors raise your hand one two
three four five six seven
eight
okay leave it at that okay
well yeah we draw a vote yeah it's all V
is on the amendment and then when the
full committee takes it up I mean there
are a lot of committees that they don't
even have a subcommittee vote they
just take it and run with it but it is
true that I have a little more rules
here okay moving right
along that's it for business
[Music]
and 15 minutes okay 15
minutes okay did
I
e
e e
okay we'll open up the subcommittee work
section session uh here in
our liquor is quicker
committee and
um so we first we have what's is
cannabis the first one up I got
everybody okay so um we're going to
retain right I'm not even sure how do we
have is that a motion on here yes it is
okay perfect all
right represented
Sullivan uh seconded
byus moves to
retain okay so who do I have here hun
pus who else is on this now there you go
you got the full
list um Walsh is here
post burrow is here buros Sullivan and
spear
spe and post is not here so
representative Ammon will sit in for
her
okay one two three four five
six who's the seven what am I
missing uh
Walsh Amon hunt
Sol his Spar oh I didn't see
okay okay so uh any discussion on
retaining Mr
cannabis all right uh no discussion all
those in favor say
I unanimous unanimous
7 seven
today okay
okay last but not least
276 Tavern license yeah
so you can be on your name you can make
the
motion this is unfortunately the
amendment uh I have not had up I we just
dropped it
on on Friday
and holiday
and uh Mike have you got did you get
from the
commission uh since they wrote it but we
can certainly give them for
they it's there it's there this is their
handwriting
okay
so
uh
so so um as you know I I've been around
a long time
and I was talking to Josh
Rogers for you Republicans might not
know who he is but he is he is the
reporter for National Public Radio New
Hampshire public radio and uh and his
his mother uh actually we see her all
the time on health insurance
issues at any rate he was I was telling
him that we were planning on doing this
bill and he says you know we were up in
Vermont and we went it we we couldn't
get in because we had our team AG
daughter with me and I said what is that
he says well cuz if you're under 21
you're barred from going into a
Tavern in
Vermont so I can only assume that's
where you got this language or you came
up with this idea
to that you need to come up speak sorry
hello Danielle ellon deputy chief New
Hampshire Liquor enforcement um I we
actually didn't pull this language from
um any
mirroring uh States the reason we did 21
plus is um there's no food there's only
alcohol there would be no reason for
them to come in maybe they want to drink
a
Coke we've so Cocktail Lounges right now
um at 9 when they or cocktail lers in
general sorry throughout the state are
18 plus unless accompanied by a parent
guard your adult spout so one of the
concerns with this is this doesn't limit
right now any type of live entertainment
or anything like that so while you have
a Tavern license that might run as a bar
um the downside of this license is it
also creates nightclubs larger dance
establishments late night establishments
um which is where the the age
restriction came
in GE sorry I don't know how my watch
learned how to do that
um okay so but so right now the because
like restaurants can close the food at 9
and they have the cocktail license
correct but they're not they they don't
bar anybody who's you're saying they
they bar anybody who's under 18 most so
by Statute it's it's um no one can be
can be in there um unless under 18
unless accompanied by a parent Guardian
our adult spouse right what we have seen
as a general business practice
throughout the industry is that once
they close the kitchen because they can
many the cocktail lers uh can close the
kitchen at 9: and become a um just just
serve serve alcohol the general business
practice there is they become a 21 plus
facility but it's not by Statute not by
Statute no however there are license
established there are liquor licenses
where they are 21
plus okay
okay uh anybody question yes how do we
get the notion of it being an optional
kind of thing for a
town um well basically uh realizing that
um there was a uh well AA started out we
had this other bill that we're about to
get which is these uh social
districts and in that social districts
I'm stared reading this whole piece
about how uh that it's a local Town vote
to create
that and I said well okay if we're g to
allow that to be a town vote you know
this particular issue um I've always
said that the opposition
to no food requirements was uh
restaurant hospitality
industry and law
enforcement because to law enforcement
uh alcohol only is just a magnet for
trouble all right you know when you look
at the problems we've had with these
knife fights and you know whatever that
goes on outside outside a bar it's
usually after 9 o00 yeah when those
things occur okay and so so I would my
theory would be is that um no no
selectman in their right mind
would ever think this is a good idea
however
um we if we're going to get in the habit
of start enabling cities and towns to do
things that they think is good remember
the premise of the bill was that
Claremont thought that this would be
good as a magnet to make people want to
live in
Claremont uh so what say so if I live in
a town and the town really doesn't want
a Tavern in there then they never take
the vote and it'll never happen oh it is
still optional it is totally H not I
wouldn't call it option I mean you can
call it an option I'm telling it's
enabling but the town has to vote for it
where are the words that say that okay
so if you look under um RSA
663 colon 5 1B C and D is that right 66
so I can clarify this a little bit
y so that that's standard language in
all of our statutes right now pertaining
to any license so that's uh we do still
have I think we're down to two dry
communities two two dry communities in
this in this in the state itself so
that's allowing um that's allowing
licensed licensed alcohol establishments
to be in the town um under
541a we are required to notify the town
of any license establishment that has
applied for a liquor license um in their
municipality or city they can then
submit any um data views concerns
objections to um that license being
issued to the commission and then
there's a hearings process for that um
this also specifically um allows the
city or town to limit the number of
tabern licenses within that municipality
if they so choose so they could say yes
we'll a tabern license but they can they
the town or municipality can can decide
to to limit that it was I'm sorry there
it was something you just said now in
the first bullet I guess I one the
commission May issue a Tavern license in
any town to which as voted except to
accept theion to have liquor licenses in
the town in general oh that's in general
that's in general correct correct and
that's standard language if you were to
look at to in any of the the statutes it
would say a cocktail lounge license will
be issued or a this that specific
license will be issued if that City all
city or town allows so this is more than
enabling it's it's the town has to pay
attention and find out that somebody has
actually applied and it's after the fact
that they find out that somebody's
applied that they've applied
yes I'm not going
to we're doing that now in our town in
our town it'll take forever before
anybody finds out that thing will go up
and it'll be active before anybody has a
chance to stop it so so we do that now
so every application that comes in the
Township's getting notification from US
asking for any objections or support for
the establishment so this we're looking
at this as if this was accepted and and
this becomes law that business doesn't
change for us
we're doing it now no I understand she's
concerned she's concerned
that that the tavern license should not
be issued unless the town has made this
affirmative
motion afferent vote so we need we need
language in this bill that says
that now is that in the social District
Bill uh cuz I was just going to list the
language from the social District Bill
and you tuck me out of it it could be
okay all right the the the good news is
this bill is not an early bill so we
have time to keep continue to work on
this okay so but at at this point we
know one thing that needs to be added to
it is that this cannot that you the
license cannot be issued until the town
has had that affirmative vote yeah I
think that we can I think the social
districts is more that the Town sets
what the social district is before the
licenses are issued so there was a
process there where there there was a
process but it was to set right what the
area was any stipulations that wasn't
necessarily a vote of the town that was
just by the the city however they do it
every every city does that different SEL
or the city council yeah I mean so
number words in my town there would be
three Selectmen would make correct two
out of the three port for example has a
liquor board has a specific board that
they actually have a liquor board that
votes and and makes decisions so every
municipality does it differently okay
I'm concerned about um point six I I
just think that that opens the door for
corruption a select board
member says oh my friend has has a has
wants a license I'm going to give it to
him and I'm going to make sure there's
no more so there's no more competition
so uh that's I would I I I don't want to
create the we always say it the New York
City taxi cab medallion situation that's
why I forgot bought the marijuana stuff
and that's why I would fight this one so
could we remove that part of it like if
if if the town is going to opt into this
I don't think we should opt into it and
then say Oh but they get to decide
there'll be one or two favored well I
think that's what that's what we're
replacing the other language with that
line would be that the town would do the
affirmative and then you could let them
in right so for all kind of purposes
that that particular language is being
removed but you will it'll say
instead right and the and the little the
the number one at the bottom obviously
so so there wouldn't be like a cap a
potential cap on licenses but we we
don't want want that we don't want that
that's not our way well I don't know CL
be our way on other things tried tried
to do it for cannabis and we had our
head handed you sure
did all four votes hey you know all four
votes of that one I'm a good orator I
convince those four people you yeah
right but you you made sure that we'll
never have marijuana in the state for
who knows how and and no corruption for
you
you look that gift horse in the mouth
and then no thank you I don't I don't I
don't regret it all
right see that had some bad teeth that
gifts horse okay is there anything else
in this in here that anybody has a
problem
with no person we allowed in the tab no
out in the tavern license yeah that's
that's what we're calling them a Tavern
license and Mr chairman if I you change
it to premise yeah if if I can just uh
reiterate from our previous testimony we
have not changed our opinion on you are
opposed to this bill we are no that's
that's important GL you reminded
us not so much opposed uh just that we
believe food needs to be part of the mix
in serving alcohol in this state so um
CH my research she she sh in the Roman
number one the two was trous the
commission May issue a Tavern
license
voted well that's actually you got it
right if you just write right in their
affirmative vote from any town
Li that's sort of a chicken of the egg
because we don't know they we don't know
they exist that that is the process now
so right now they apply they cannot they
apply for the license they cannot get
the license without Town
approval right now in any license
whether it be a combination or a
restaurant or yeah any prevence
yeah
yeah no no they have it's a No Object I
shouldn't say an approval it's a no
objection from the town so they're g a
time frame they're given a time frame
where they can submit an objection some
of them do submit approvals um but then
but there's a time frame to say if you
object within right now it's 15 so this
is a waiver from that process because
this is saying is no you're not we're
not waiting you know from there to hear
uh to hear if you have not have any
problem with it is that you have to make
affirmative we can we can clean the
language up so that it would that they
have to have actually approval from the
town
right the six the
6635 is just the town accepting that
they'll allow license alcohol licensed
establishments in general doesn't say
what kind what type right that's
standard language throughout title 13
the town has to accept that they have to
not be a dry community so we can issue a
license per statute if the town is voted
to be a dry Community anyways anyways
anyway doesn't mattering that this the
this is the next so that first one is
you might want to Reber things here a
little bit and that's standard language
but what it sounds like we're looking to
add is that there has the town has to
either approve the tavern or vote to
have a tabern license have an
affirmative affirmative vote by
affirmative vote has to be affirmative
vote for the town before before the
license is
issued and if there if it if there is
opposition that triggers due
process that'll trigger a
hearing right now just put it would have
shut down the conversation right you
would shut down the conversation of
being a Tavern license right now yeah so
you
to there's two proc so right now if the
town objects there's a hearings process
for the lensey to go through within that
municipality in front of the hearings
officer for the commission where people
can submit their all their all their
infavor of or opposed to that's it right
now this sounds like this would just be
there's an approval you're going to
allow a Tavern license or not so so it
doesn't if the town votes against
approval if the town votes for it that
means that hearing process doesn't occur
because the now the town has actually
voted to approve it if they don't
approve so another words there's a
waiver from that statute well that that
particular requirement no I I think I
think you have to do this in two ways
the town has to allow the tavern license
applications to go in but there's still
the process on the application itself
who the lenses are Who The Operators are
so so that would still to me the
application should say right on the
application the town you know please
include the town's vote they voted for
it it should just be you know please
report you know when was what was the
date when the town voted for it okay
that's what you should do just be on the
application so because you would ignore
the application if they don't F in that
they don't have
it you follow me there no okay in other
words d okay the whole process is right
now is if you want to get a liquor
license you download the form and you
fill it out and you submit it to the
commission the commission does not just
approve it because you submitted the
form they then have a couple of steps
they go through and one of them is do
you have your liability insurance do you
have do you that that we're going to
send a letter out to your town
and what's the time frame that the town
has to
respond right now they right now it's 15
days okay so within 15 days the town has
to say we have a problem if the town
doesn't say they don't have a problem
then they The Liquor Commission just
checked it off that's the process now
for all our license you know for our
liquor license what we're doing is a
little bit different with this one this
one is on that application it needs to
say has the town voted for this license
and what was the date they made that
positive affirmative
vote they're going to read it when they
see the
form the form will have it on there and
say what was when the town affirmed
it the town if the town voted no then
then if they submit that that
application the the liquid commission
would say no you're re Ed because you
did not check off the box that the town
voted for it won't
happen it's all about checking the Box
other words when you when you f when you
fill out a form when you fill out a form
with any getting any license and permits
and stuff there going to be a bunch of
boxes you have to check okay yeah all
right and so the check is for with the
commission to say okay we've got this we
got that You' submitted this you
submitted that that one of those items
is going to be did the town of the town
because one of the items is that the
Liquor Commission checks The Liquor
Commission checks the Box correct so one
of the other questions is that when it
asks the town the town they can say to
the town you have a problem about where
the location
is because the tavern is putting in the
location right don't you guys one of the
questions you're asking the town is not
just you know you know for you have any
objections what objections may you have
well one of them would be well we don't
like it that's right next to the school
or we don't like it because you know
it's next to a church or we don't like
it you know because it's in a in in our
it violates our
zoning okay can be any one of those
things the town can object to then they
have that
hearing and in that hearing if the town
will come up and make a convincing
argument that they don't want it in that
that area in that zone then the
commission will not they will not check
that box and the application will be
rejected about uh I don't know two
months ago when it was a little warmer
out we had a
shootout we had a shootout in nashille
in front of a bar yes and uh two people
I think were shot and I don't know I
think one of them was
killed and
that bar I don't know what I mean I've
seen it every single day and it's a it's
a it was a messy place to begin with I
don't know how they were allowed to stay
in business but they
did uh it's closed now it's boarded
up
but I want to see the town be much more
proactive about stopping this as opposed
to just checking a little box if they
have a if they they have not proactively
said I want a Tavern correct if they
have not said it correct then no taverns
that's the end of it make sure this is
question number
one right off the top has the town voted
to airally approve it I'm wonder it has
to be number one I think
Kino is has the same thing that's right
has a similar thing where the town had
the town but it had to be done in a town
meeting formerly in the town they had
accept in the town meeting are they
going to allow lift that language we can
do it similar to that that's lift that
language that's perfect Kino is
definitely a good example because my
town kept voting against
it Keith next then represent W okay
thank you um it sounds like the we need
an amendment that has that language the
enabling language like the actual text
that goes on the ballot in statute like
the keyot yeah exactly and that's where
I got it from when we do the social
districts Bill
okay okay no all representative walls
then representative BS okay maybe this
is more of a would you believe
but I just had to do a permit which was
a unbelievable process for a retaining
wall which involves Dees and Dees this
is for you Carri DS will not process I
mean there's tons that had to be filled
out by the applicant but they were
specifically looking for the signature
of the Town Clerk and the um
conservation
commissioner so I mean that can be part
of the process I bet you that is in the
Kino Kino language it has to be some
yeah our so our we have there's two
processes right now so for a general
license um that's where there's no
objection from the town town has the
ability to respond we give them the
opportunity to respond if they some do
some there's other types of licenses
such as a a catering license for a
catering event or a one- day event where
you need actual signatures from the fire
department the chief of police the town
selectman you know things specific
signatures saying you're allowed to have
this event again some of them are in the
Town Square or you know they're they're
in in public places that affect the town
so there there's two proc processes to
that um it sounds though like what
they're looking for for this is rather
than that the process for the specific
license would still apply but you can
only apply for the tavern license in the
town if the town has voted to allow
Tavern license applications to be
submitted it still doesn't there's still
the General application process which is
reviewing uh you know the applicants the
the that would still apply but the town
would have to vote it sounds like the
language preferred is similar know the
town would have to aote that they would
allow the a Tavern license to be apply
right so the default is no Tavern and
they have to apply to get a Tavern the
the town would have to vote to allow
Tavern license applications to be
accepted and then the the applicant
itself would have to apply and then they
would go through the normal application
process that would be great if you can
write that up just a quick
question how how do so we have statutory
language in this new Amendment uh
who proposes that to go onto the ballot
can can uh It Be petitioned by the
members of the town is that yeah any
warant article can be by petition 10
people so it's not just up to the select
board to
decide or
the okay meanless if they want they can
find 10 signature you know they I mean I
assume they have authority to put things
in the warrant but I you know like the
planning board I know does things the
planning board has to be a vote of the
planning board to put more articles
on
so representative
bureaus thank
you this may fall into the category of
dumb idea but she already thinks it is
but have ever been anything like on the
applications for a license that say you
know taverns are encouraged to have like
bar food like popcorn or something
because you know just a statistic about
what alcohol does to you without
food yeah we could put that language on
the I mean you at this point this
doesn't exist so you could put any
language on there is that I mean is that
make sense or it will not do anything I
think it's at the end of the day it's
the business the business
plan but I assume that they're liable if
there's if somebody goes out and crashes
their car out yeah just like any other
license establishment
y there is no doubt there's no doubt in
my mind that to get
to get one of these Tavern licenses in
Vermont or Massachusetts that the the
liability insurance is
higher but I mean you're you're
balancing that off with you know the
fact that you don't have the food you
know the costs of the food so and that
was representative Sullivan's argument
right the beginning ago was that you
know you want to you want to streamline
make it easy to just open up one of
these things so but one of so uh we
never discussed the ual license
fee just
sto of course thank you um as you and I
have spoken uh Mr chairman uh this arose
from my
predecessors years ago yes and and the
deterrent was a pretty
hefty um fee fee um I think at the end
of the day you establishments such like
such as this that don't have food along
with them bring other Dynamics to them
some of which have been mentioned today
um it takes a larger enforcement effort
um which is is of course uh
car equal equal to fees that that are
being charged for a license type so um
uh
I haven't researched the background of
those fees back in the day but it was a
$10,000 I thought it was as sponsor of
the bill I think it was 10 grand but I
think at the end of the day our largest
25 no that's what it started out I don't
think that ey um our largest fee right
now is 1280 and the amount of effort
that would be put into enforcement would
far for a lack of a better term would
bury that number
it 1280 would not
beate that's our highest fee now that
cocktail just shows you how easy it is
to get a liquor license in New Hampshire
it's only
1280 okay plus a business
plan so you don't have a number yet or
we don't have a number right now we'll
have Aiden work Aiden's actually
listening to us right now so we can have
him can you do some just some multiple
of that fee mean
that seems like a reasonable way to do
it and then it would it would adjust
over time if if you guys raised one it
would automatically go up two times we
don't like raising and lowering fees we
don't we like I'm not saying we should
or shouldn't I'm just saying if for some
point in the future somebody decides
they need to raise the fee and this is a
multiple of the highest fee then it
would go up accordingly right so I'm not
advocating for raising fees let me
multiple of the 1280 you're saying that
the answer yeah answer should be uh four
or five times the 1280 I I I don't know
what the time should the amount should
be but I'm saying that might be a good
way to do
it okay you got that Iden I I don't
that's just an idea it's uh let's a
let's not make it so pun punitive that
people can't like get in
so we made it
uh 80 *
5 well if you want to get back to where
we were
before we don't need to use that as a
benchmark I mean we're not trying to
like kill this before it gets out of the
gate are we or maybe we are that's
probably what people are actually trying
to stand corrected just that's probably
what everybody but me want I after
saying what I have just said we now have
my the third the third leg has just
arrived in the room the Chiefs Chiefs of
police and and I assume is in opposition
to this amendment
if you know what it
is
so yeah no I'm assuming okay and just
for informational purposes like our
cigar bars right now are very similar
other than they have they have uh
introduced cigar smoking in the
establishment right they don't have food
and how much is there they they are are
some of our yeah 12 1280 they're 1280 um
but at the same time the amount of
effort that the mun Municipal
jurisdictions put into enfor uh safety
efforts let's call them Life Safety
efforts um they are some of the
establishments that you hear on the news
quite often so perfect example that 1280
is really not the right number if you
remove food
I'm sure from I won't speak on their
behalf but I'm sure on the chief's point
of view they are usually the First
Responders to these incidents that it's
it looks as if it's an unfunded mandate
all right let's uh let's go with
640 6,400 that's a five time that
works five times
128 I I'll let I'll let the Senate I
mean I think the Senate's going to kill
this bilding
well actually not because you know all
the senat the members of the Senate
Commerce Committee are kind of excited
about it but some of them are so so
anyway uh so we'll do 640 and I just
make one more comment this was the best
solution to the previous bill that was
submitted that eliminated food um as you
know I'm a bit of a technical person
when it comes to the liquor statutes um
there were some there were some concerns
with that because it it didn't El
eliminate food requirements for other
license establishments
uh by by definition you still have to
have a kitchen but you didn't have to
have food so there was still there was
so this was kind of if you're going to
eliminate food this would this is the
cleanest way for us in terms of
Licensing and enforcement to do
it okay any other comments that
represent
WS yeah I have a question so
if in theory if this tavern existed if
they wanted to serve food could
they yes they could they could certainly
Ser there no one there's no borrowing
them from Ser boring ni
cute they they still have to they would
still have to have their the the their
board the uh housing not what is it uh
what is usually in each town they have a
health officer the health officer offer
that would have some you know weighing
in on on what the kitchen is supposed to
look like and if they did put it in a
kitchen then then they've got to comply
with it the rules about multiple sinks
and refrigerators that have thermostats
in them
and okay
great and yes you are opposed to this
amendment but you're willing to help me
out in getting it drafted okay Mike want
to weigh
in
any Mikey doesn't like
this he does I'm not sure what you'd
like me to say other than no thank
you uh you know just emphasize why you
will you suspect your members will in
the in C in town take this up you would
I think are you against it obviously the
cities and towns weighing in is is
better than just eliminating food
requirements so certainly can get on you
know appreciate that we still don't like
it as a concept and I think frankly um
the real issue for for us would be that
you know $6,400 is not enough of a
licensing Fe for what this is going to
require of local law enforcement plus
the liquid commission Etc um you know I
I think the original Tavern Bill going
back to your comment earlier I think it
started at 25,000 it might have come
down during the whole delivery process
but but I think it was at $25,000 and
frankly I think it should be more than
that but that's just my personal opinion
I haven't talked to anybody about it yet
because I just saw this for the first
time today so uh that said I think this
is just asking for trouble um and there
will be municipalities that will likely
adopt it um and I just I can't see much
good coming of it
frankly not sure what else I could do to
change your mind but anyway we just want
to get you on record got
it okay thanks thank you Beth you want
to
uh you're not you're you're you're not
okay with the bill because you're okay
with the commission's
possession only other one other person
in the room and I'm sure you don't care
right right and and like I said you
weren't here but I I would assume that
no town would vote to this in their you
know well you never know you there's
always going to be some small town um
that you know that that that I but I
would think that the small you know the
uh the law enforcement you know the
chief chief would point out you know
you're just inviting you know Riff Raff
and and my my personal feeling is that
I I've I I've never seen a classy
one I mean to me they're all hole in the
walls but we are going to change it so
that the town has to allow taverns
before they can even apply exactly okay
exactly
so okay any other this bill is not an
early bill so we're I just wanted to
have this hearing because uh we had
originally taken action in the uh
subcommittee had taken had voted on it
before but um I I it it felt like
unfinished business
so anybody else any other
comments no no
fun what so a night fight is much more
fun to have you know have a night fight
out in front
right right well no they they're all
happening after 9: with the food the
food's been shut
off right so if we we should repeal that
say no you got to serve food all the way
all the way through
what it's
thee yeah that's the VFW yes I agree
with you he's when I go in the VFW I
don't see too many people that is
true you
know I'm not saying like I'm not
saying is your mic on make sure we get
this all recorded yes I'm not saying
that there isn't there isn't crime with
these things I just think there it's a
lot of like
fearmongering
and I've lived in places where there
isn't like a night fight every single
night because people are out at a bar
that doesn't sell food I
mean I don't know it's I the biggest the
we we do know if you look at the data
and I have looked at the data and I I
briefly explored writing my my thesis in
grad school on crime
on related to these topics and it was a
while ago granted but like the biggest
predictor of crime is age it's somebody
in their 20 is far more likely to be a
criminal than somebody in their 70s or
80s or 40s like me you know so it's like
so the idea that like oh all we have to
do is slap a food requirement on and and
crime just Falls it's just it's just not
entirely true you know you got to you
got to be able to tease out those two
differences and I think I think that
there's a lot of fearmongering going on
around around these things and I know
I'm not making much Headway in
convincing people of that and that's
okay I'm glad with this compromise and
maybe we'll see a few few towns do it
and maybe it it leads to something else
but um it is frustrating when I listen
to people just say oh my God this is
going to the world is going to end we
should all be terrified to exist in
society more because we don't no longer
have food requirements or whatever and
that's just the part that frustrates me
when I hear these arguments
representa Bros I I actually the knives
or guns aren't what concerns me is
people getting in their cars without
food in their system but
again people don't don't have to eat
food like you you're making an
assumption built into that argument that
when somebody goes out they're going out
to eat primarily and not drink if
somebody is going out to be social and
drink then that is their primary goal
and the mere fact that there's food
there they may have already eaten before
they showed up you know I mean a lot of
people do that they eat and then they go
out to drinks and be socialized there's
two different things going on and the
thing you don't like is the idea that
people are out there drinking
irresponsibly overc consuming and making
bad decisions whether it's knife fights
or drunk driving those are all bad
things that are all outlawed that we
shouldn't we shouldn't encourage right
the idea that the Magic Bullet to solve
those problems is to simply just have
food I think is just a bit naive and
that's that's my argument on WR yeah I I
I have to say I disagree that that's the
Magic Bullet what I I personally believe
because we have the same food
requirement when it comes to off-
premise lenses we haven't even talked
about that okay um we had in the past uh
we had a certain representative who kept
insisting that spam was on the shelves
in the
stores and and I failed to find spam
when I went and did you Convenience St
check so but I I think going back to um
when and I always say I love to been in
the room in
1937 when after the the prohibition was
repealed and how they decided to come up
with the system we came up with um I
think it was more about uh making sure
that the people who were in The Business
of selling alcohol uh were fine
upstanding citizens
and credible because that to them it was
all about you know Al Capone and uh you
know Speak Easy and on and on and on and
I think that that was what was really
bothering because they weren't so much
worried about drunk driving back then um
you know because cars couldn't go very
fast and uh so I I think that they were
they were trying and intentionally to
like I said when the food when it came
to the off- premise licenses they really
wanted to make sure that every Town's
little
IGA you know the the grer the Village
grer um was the one who got the liquor
license because uh that they're they
have an investment they're going to be
you know competent they're going to be
responsible and they would be making
sure that that they weren't serving
drunks and they weren't and uh I think
the same thing when it goes to
restaurants is is is if you don't have
that food requirement and I have to say
most of all the vfw's do have kitchen
I I've never been in a VFW that didn't
have a kitchen but that that they the
issue for them um you know in terms of
how they they got the waiver well they
had the they also had the smoking waiver
you know they didn't we didn't ban them
from smoking you know but I think that
when it comes to any general
establishment and and really refers back
to my comment that the ones the ones I
know of in Massachusetts that I've been
to over the years and are hole in the
walls U is that um how how financially
responsible how comp you know how much
skin do they have to make sure that they
really
are caring people they really are making
sure they're not over serving and if you
if you have a restaurant now you have a
much larger investment you have a lot
more but you know way this you know
would to me a Tavern you could just take
any hole in the wall property you know
that could have been a dry cleaner it
could have been anything and you throw a
bunch of tables and chairs in a in a in
a and you know make your own bar or you
can buy one off on Amazon and bada bing
bada boom and now you're now you're in
the in the the liquor business so if you
lose your liquor license because you've
had three incidents or whatever or
somebody dies and they shut you down you
know whatever all those those fines I
don't care I don't have that much
investment into this property and that's
my concern I appreciate that John cuz
that's a better argument than all the
other arguments we've heard good so I
appreciate that um and I mean I think
that maybe the the higher
licensing and Licensing is annual right
you got to pay that every year yes yes
yeah so the higher licensing and there's
still some investment so I think there's
some investment I mean certainly if
somebody is trying to start off um
starting a new bar like they might be
able to do it on the cheap but they're
still going to be in it for a five
figure number it's not like it's free
money that's why I I was my multiplier
of and I'm saying even even ignoring
that for a second that's an important
part of it but I'm saying if I wanted to
go start up a bar tomorrow and this my
town approved this I mean I would I I
would have to find some I'd have a
minimum a lease of of of a year that I
have to pay I'd have I'd be in it for
five figures right it's not it's not
trivial you got some investment yeah
yeah be it's not a trivial amount of
money and certainly if I acted irr
responsibity liquor shut me down in six
months I'm out five figures well that's
a lot of money for most people so I I do
think that there's your point is a
really good one I think the best one
I've heard yet um and but I do think
that there's some level of that here it
doesn't require a mult a sixf figure
investment the way a restaurant does to
get there I still I still think people
have an incentive to be good stewards
but I think that's the the food thing
I'm not I I already said that if the
town wanted it fine knock yourself out
but I do think that the investment in
what it takes to do food is the
investment that keeps it straight that's
my point yeah and
and even if even if I don't know I I
just see these places in Nashville where
we're having these and it's not a night
fight it was a freaking gunfight and
people were standing there you know so
Mike did I just make your point or did
you have something else that you wanted
to
add yes please come on up
so I know the comment was made that you
know Claremont wants this because it's
going to revive their downtown and
frankly that is a stretch um most small
smaller towns a restaurant is an anchor
in these towns right this is where
people go for their special occasions
the nights out those kinds of things so
it has a much broader appeal this is
where an instance where you close the
kitchen at 9:00 and you might turn into
a nightclub or something to appeal to a
younger audience this would work in that
kind of a scenario but if anyone thinks
that somebody's going to open a night
Club in downtown claremont's going to
change their economic it's just not that
that's not how the industry works could
they make a little bit of money sure but
there's not enough people that live in
the area to make this whole thing
sustainable that's why they're having
the problem it's not really because of
the licensing structure if that makes
sense any would you believe though this
might make an option where somebody
doesn't want to be in the liquor
business and they can actually have
somebody who opens up a small Tavern
Tavern license and then somebody has
like a pizza shop next door and they
don't want to be together but they they
mutually work well together and I have
seen that you go to Boseman Montana and
there are bars that don't sell anything
but alcohol and then in the same
building in a different you know right
next door there's the Peta pit and which
opened up when I was in college there
and there's also a Tarantino's pizza
that had opened up while I was there and
so sometimes having more freedom will
give entrepreneurs different
opportunities to figure out what where
their Niche is going to be and I feel
like that that's the part that maybe
you're discounting in your argument well
but I think what I the point that I made
in my original testimony is that you're
essentially taking the profitable piece
so the pizza joint's probably selling a
few beers with with pizzas whatever to
go they're not selling the beer they're
sending you next door I understand that
there's but I I just been but what I'm
suggesting is that the pizza right now
pizza shop right now in New Hampshire
may actually be selling beers or
whatever it might be so now you're
essentially saying that this business
that was built on the business model
where food was required and let's just
take a small right just take the pizza
thing out of it small restaurant
whatever whatever it might be it has a
small percentage of its business that is
probably alcohol which is very
profitable business for them and now
you're going to allow somebody to open
up next door from much lower overhead
basically free um and they're
essentially going to steal that business
from them and then now this business is
no longer viable so now you've
essentially put somebody who has already
put their their fam's equity and and
livelihood and everything else and you
put them in a in a very precarious
position and the one last thing question
that I have for this discussion is if if
you have a license of this type what is
it to prevent this license type from
opening at 11:00 at night and running
till 1 1 in the morning could run for
two or three hours total total time
correct so it has almost no labor it's
just moving booze through the door and
frankly that's when the worst of
decisions are made and it leads to
pregaming and all the other fun things
we hear about frankly I I think we were
just asking for
problems and that's why we're going to
charge the extra fee cuz will have a
Liquor Commission cover the G respond
and watching watching drunks enter the
enter enter The Establishment and that
won't cover the gas that the First
Responders are going to have to have to
come to the first gun fight not not to
mention the second and the third guy no
no no we just want our our enforcement
division to take care of us okay and
local police and that's why and local
police and that's why I'm saying the
local police would say to the you know
to the to the select or to you know the
war i' say please do not vote this is
you know if you think it's bad enough
for you know just just pulling over
people on the highway all night long but
imagine what if now if now you're we're
not doing that we're not getting the
Speeders we now we're we're parked out
in front of this this Watering Hole well
and at $6,400 is there a portion of that
that's going to be shared with the city
and town to cover their local
enforcement because they're going to be
the first Rec call right they're going
to be the first ones to respond to
whatever the incident is correct and how
much of that's an unfunded mandate no
not me any did I'm just asking a
question they voted for it that's why I
did asking a question I specifically
that particular problem when I said you
know why the high fee even really really
belongs to his chief well that's fine
let's just have the the let the Chiefs
fight that at the Town level let the
police F will take care of it that's
what Beth will do thanks for listening
all right I think we've had a very
Lively discussion and good discussion
here and uh and we'll end this
subcommittee
that's it for today